When I worked in the shipyards and I worked next to a journeyman welder man,...
...we made the same, it was equal pay.
I couldn't be prouder to be here today.
Not only did you help win the war,...
...but you also helped to open up opportunities for women.
Ultimately, equal pay is not just an economic issue...
...for millions of Americans and their families;...
...it's also about whether we're willing to build an economy that works for everybody,...
...whether we're gonna do our part to make sure that our daughters...
...have the same chances to pursue their dreams as our sons.
Part of that is fighting for fair pay for women.
Because when women succeed, America succeeds.
When women succeed, America succeeds.
It's true.
America should be a level playing field, a fair race for everybody,...
...a place where anybody who's willing to work hard has a chance to get ahead.
And restoring that opportunity for every American, men and women,...
...has to be a driving focus for our country.
And it can be the same today if the women just keep at it and stick to it.